[Music]
and almost got away news analyst
submitted by David's turtledoves a
family returned home from a road trip to
find a hitchhiker had clung to the
underside of their RV whoa I'd be scared
to do - to have some crazy [ __ ] Jason
Bourne's [ __ ] some Indiana Jones [ __ ]
you want to hear the craziest part to
sleep while he was doing it right there
to go nap I was whole underside is
[ __ ] hot okay he sort of has no ass
skated right off all gone that's pretty
crazy
no the crazy [ __ ] is he he held on for
four days what boys you know he's got
poopy butt yeah he must be like there
must have been like a rest spot where
it's not just straight holding you know
he was balancing on the axle oh my god
get it laying on top of it like a sloth
like it he just gets to like kind of hug
yeah me too his pants and his ass the
movies movies you think like this yeah
for four days that's impossible so he's
probably like careful with your arms not
coming down your legs I mean he's had a
like get off and stretch a little bit or
something right like I pictured this shy
when it parked like he [ __ ] went
underneath and rolled out and went to
the bathroom did all this [ __ ] rolled
back under mission impossible yeah yeah
I mean as long as my RV wasn't [ __ ] up
I I guess I wouldn't mind it's more like
it's a woman Todd yeah it's like that's
a little weird bro but alright let me
just get back on and we're about to
leave in 10 minutes I'd be more worried
about him am I you okay yeah I'm gonna
like buy some food we're gonna hold onto
the bag like that little ladder or on
the top looks like you're not gonna come
in but get back under though man that
one's getting [ __ ] outta you know if you
just like got off at a rest stop and
he's dude like rolled out from in here
oh [ __ ] yeah just be a little odd saying
this weird thing he didn't hit no
[ __ ] like grocery store [ __ ] speed
bump
I mean like oh yeah go beat or if you
like sped up you don't need speed up
it's like dude good got some airtime
just see a guy split in half and he just
rolls out the other side huh good god
it's like a tomato yeah every time you
had a bump all yours coming from dude
you guys know that highway on the way to
Mammoth they got those [ __ ] wraps who
feels right but it feels like ramps
because if you [ __ ] speed down you
you feel like one feels good yeah I like
to do that yes this vistors me held on
for more than 300 miles so this family
they're doing this camping trip and
friends and they're thinking that he got
on when they were here at this port the
city here in France oh sure you could
drive under the water no they took a
ferry yeah you drive onto it no cuz I
thought they had a tunnel
yeah so this was the whole route that
the family took and this is where they
found he friendly also this [ __ ]
was on a boat under a car yeah an RV
this RV Wow I'd be too scared man yeah
so the reason why they found out he
stowed away was because when they
finally got home they live in a really
like rural area so it's an all-white
neighborhood and the one that popped out
was like a black kid or something yeah a
Sudanese yeah okay so they gave them
like some Orangina and like some snacks
that's what I was looking out like that
looks like an Orangina yeah this is good
and then they call the police and
immigration to help him out oh I thought
they called [ __ ] immigration out
there is crazy out of control
yeah they were wondering like well how
do we get past the border control like
how do they not check don't they stick
with the mirrors he put his face in here
like a massage table the bottom is here
of him inside I want to see how he fits
I wanna go back in there I'd be like can
you show us how you did it and then I'll
take a picture of it and he'll smile
with the thumbs-up dude with all that
work that he did um I'd be like all
right man you're good you just use
everybody like work for me or something
wrong I know dedicated that's human
being that's true yeah cuz they found
him like what the son of a family they
just saw like this random black dude
just walking around and they're like
he's not from around here is it that's a
stretch though really if you think about
it to be like this guy doesn't belong
here in this rural ass area
he must have stowed away underneath my
RV I'm pretty sure they asked him come
from I took a ride under that car necks
are still in the house don't you get
your ID yeah he they asked them they
were like Halle Berry there
and then he held up four fingers and
then they were like for four hours he's
like no he's four months [ __ ]
I'm so curious like what he ate I know
honey survived for four days I mean like
a pee poop on our car although I could
just whip my dick out and pee or I could
just take a Dookie yeah I just turn yeah
might be kinda nice you think I'd go oh
the occasion and do next I mean imagine
if all you gotta do is it's like push
your butt out well it's like riding and
then you just let that [ __ ] go well
hopefully you're going in the right
direction oh oh cause if it rips and it
comes back must be you both gotta be
careful next time meeting in RV trip
even look down there they actually did
at that same spot where they think he
jumped on they went inside they stopped
at a supermarket and then when they went
back into the van they pulled in like an
immigrant out because he was trying to
like go into the van and so they think
wow that was probably his friend or
someone or maybe pop like a decoy yeah
oh they got split damn dude trying to
get into their van yeah RV what is their
end result where are they trying to go
they're just trying to know so you're
talking specifically of the refugee
problem right
so there's several things going on I
mean there's there's war there's a civil
war in Yemen there's a [ __ ] ton of like
conflict in northern and I think it's
East Africa
yeah don't quote me on that but there
you know of course the Syrian and all
those refugees yeah yeah but I thought
the refugee crisis was mainly in the
Middle East but I didn't know that there
was a huge surge out in Africa too
because when we were in France on the
way to the hub yeah you see that [ __ ]
and on the way back to I mean not the
highway but on the way to Paris and then
back to the airport it's crazy
yeah it looks like skin roll for like
[ __ ] miles man there's nothing but
tents that are like you didn't see it
it's crazy the way they're right we will
get into town that's where it starts and
then when we go further in is yeah it's
nicer but it was just like a whole
refugee town there are suburbs where
there's nothing but tents and and on the
way to the where was that that that that
palace yeah yeah oh sorry palace of
versaille when you're on the train and
you look next to the river right there's
like kind of like this it's kind of like
what do you call it like a river
man-made River but like a gutter thing
but it's huge like an aqueduct or a
canal is like a canal but there's no
water in it but there's nothing but
shanty like homes and tents and it goes
on for [ __ ] miles dude and I was like
watched our flock this is [ __ ] crazy
and if you notice like majority of the
people that were like in need of help
and trying to sell us trinkets and stuff
like that they were black they weren't
middle-eastern mm-hmm that's right so a
lot of the refugees are coming from
Africa - and and so I guess it's so bad
over there that they'd rather be
imprisoned in Europe then in like
wherever they're from that's crazy yeah
Gover um is like [ __ ] [ __ ] up in
Africa that's why I like the US has such
a strong presence in Africa that nobody
knows about like we have so much
military there right now because they're
trying to stabilize yeah no no we're
trying to like we're trying to like to
make sure that Isis and stuff doesn't
come through it's like we left that [ __ ]
unchecked in the Middle East and then
they got strong it up there and so then
now they have affiliates in Africa that
are [ __ ] [ __ ] up you know what's
crazy I know about some of the cousins
but Special Forces friends and he was
telling me that according to the United
Nations the United States Army was
supposed to be there no and they're
there they have fake passports and fake
identities and Oscar's hella Navy SEALs
hella Green Berets that are there under
different names they can't even call
back yeah it might be John Tran but it's
over there his name is [ __ ] Lawrence
cow or some [ __ ] and then
he's over there just Lords callable
they're over there advising yeah but
it's but it's called direct action what
just means kill [ __ ] and
they're just over there I'm like that is
some crazy like movie share you don't
think that it is but it is that way yeah
I mean it's it's just chaos out there
right now and I think um
that's why I like not to get too deep
into politics but that's literally what
the whole immigration crisis is about
and they don't want people to you know
come in here in droves what sucks so
much about France that this fool is like
nah France ain't good enough I'm gonna
keep going to England unless he had
family somewhere or something like that
he's trying to get to oh yeah yeah did
they ask him like why you going so
[ __ ] North to this little rule English
town they probably did was article but
yeah like there are saying that in that
area where he stowed away yeah that
that's becoming like a pressure point
for illegal immigration oh there's too
much heat then I got a pass from this
place so he was so then they did call
immigration and a police officer and
then they aged assess him as a minor so
he was passed to the care of he [ __ ]
carbon dated his ass all this he took
his pants down and touches balls that
like this 16 what's happening is like in
the major cities they're kind of
overwhelmed so they can't get the care
or help that they need because there's
just way too many so then now they're
bleeding into the suburbs or like other
places and looking for you know help out
there because they could they could not
get us bring people in or whatever was
dope those I ended up in England cuz you
know like when you're a slob depending
on which country you landing you develop
that accent
ten years he's gonna sound like [ __ ]
a butler from like Fresh Prince he's
gonna sound classy versus standing like
just a hole by challege SP that's good
[Music]